[Applause]
they got a send-off
a reaction to all this attention and I
mean it's it's great that the media
wants to write and are interested in
climate related subjects even though
there are many others who are more
relevant than than this but yeah
obviously the rest of his parties
I mean I am not telling anyone what to
do or what not to do I'm just doing this
because I want to do this myself and I
am one of the very very few people in
the world who actually can do this and
then I think I should take that chance
to do this
to do that
I mean of course this is a big challenge
I don't think I mean I'm not the one who
are going to take us there it is Boris
and Pierre so but of course it's going
to be challenging for everyone on the
boat probably that is what you have to
expect and and I mean there are always
going to be people who don't understand
or don't accept the United science and I
mean I will just ignore them because I
mean I'm only acting and communicating
on the science and if they don't like
that then I mean what have I got to do
with that and I'm not going to the
United States I'm going to North and
South America so I'm going to travel
around on both continents of course
I mean it's I'm not concerned about
reactions what I'm concerned about is
whether we we will do something or not
whether the people in power will react
and act with necessary force and where
was I yeah and of course there are
people who want climate delayers who
want to do everything to shift the focus
from the climate crisis due to something
else or want to to make people question
the science and I'm not worried about
that i'm just going to do as i as i want
to do and as i think will have most
impact
wait
I have had a very warm welcome I haven't
been public about where I'm going so
that I have been welcomed by people who
I know and who are helping me and so
yeah
save yourself the journey and set an
example that you can attend these things
virtually
of course I can do that and I have
attended several conferences and
meetings by video link
but unfortunately my experience is that
those attendances doesn't get any
attention at all and I have been invited
there to speak I've not been invited
there to speak on link and I think it
will be it will do more good if if I and
the people there young people were
actually there instead of by video link
I think I I get my energy from that I
know this is a very big problem and I
have read a lot of and I am I sort of
understand the problem in a way in in
many ways and then I just have decided
that I am going to do everything I can
and I think that is what keeps me going
just the dedication I know I'm I will do
everything I can and also the fact that
some things are actually changing I
think that's especially the mindsets of
many people is changing even if that is
not enough and even if it's not fast
enough it's at least something so it's
not for nothing
with many was
no yes I mean I don't see if anyone else
has seceded I'm not I'm not that special
I can't convince everyone and instead of
speaking to to me and to the school
striking children and teenagers they
should be talking to to actual
scientists and experts in this area
as I said before I don't tell people
what to do I don't tell anyone what to
do and what not to do and I will just
leave it there I mean people can do what
they want and yeah and what I am how I'm
thinking about these this trip or I
think it will be very quite an adventure
it will be a very new experience for me
at least and I and of course I expect it
to be challenging sometimes and but also
good some most of the time I mean maybe
I don't know seasickness I mean of
course many things but I I will have to
manage that it's not it's not a lot more
people in the world are suffering a lot
more than that
so yeah
I mean the same thing
I mean that the oceans are crucial and I
mean both its as of course as every
other ecosystem but also in regulating
the climate and it gives us much of the
air we breathe and I mean so I mean that
we are in a crisis not only a climate
crisis but of course lots of the climate
crisis is happening in the ocean as well
the oceans are of course also impacted
by that but also that we are also facing
an ecological crisis which effects I
mean not only the climates and weather
patterns but also environments and yeah
you inspired me everything
what advice would you give somebody like
trying to make
I don't it's in the beginning I I mean
my voice wasn't hurt at all as so many
others and I just tried different ways
until I found some kind of method to and
that made my voice heard and so I think
it's of course it's individually for
everyone and you just have to be
creative and come up with maybe
something new to do there are so
incredibly many things you can do and
since this is such an incredibly big and
global problem it needs to be tackled
from every possible angle so I mean
there's no I mean you can do so much
I what I'm thinking now is that I'm only
going to fill take like step by step and
I will have to do as I feel of course if
I I mean I don't have anything planned
right now but I'm going to travel around
there for I don't know how long and that
is intentionally because I wanted to be
very loose and not to to have a very
tight and a very tight schedule because
I want to change things as time goes by
and so I but so yeah I don't I don't
know yet how I will get home
[Music]
that your
I am definitely not more than a human
being
and I mean I don't I think it's good
that's I mean someone's voice is getting
hurt there are so many people whose
voice I are getting hurt in this matter
so every every person who fights for the
same thing and whose voice gets hurt is
very important and and it doesn't really
matter who that person is what
background that person has as long as it
has dedication and wants to fight for a
better world
I will just have to have to see I was
tested sailing two days ago I think and
we were out for several hours and I
didn't feel bad I didn't feel anxious or
anything I felt like I think I felt
seasick for like 1 or 2 minutes and then
it just stopped so I don't know I will
just have to see to get on the boat and
see what what happens and that is also
very very exciting and I have never done
anything like this before so I can't
really say what is going to be the
biggest challenge but I will just have
to find that out
yeah these few days preparing and
packing everything has been I think they
would have been good
I have they have been very incredibly
helping I am eternally grateful for what
they for what they have done and for
what they are doing and I yeah I think
it's very very brave of them to do
something like this to just I mean I
mean they contacted us and and because
they heard I was looking for a way to
get across the Atlantic Ocean and we
have been in contact with several boats
of course and considered every option
but they were the ones who sounded more
most sincere and most dedicated and so
so yeah I think I'm very grateful for
them for everyone in the team and also
to all the volunteers who have helped us
I mean we will we will just simply have
to see that I mean if they succeed in
reducing enough co2 emissions then of
course they have succeeded in doing that
and if they if they won't then they
haven't and as it looks now it doesn't
look very good
yes I'm very much looking forward to
that if we see any at any marine animals
and yeah
that will be an experience
it will be the anniversary of your first
strike while you're in the middle of the
Atlantic I guess
how do you plan to market yes it's the
anniversary of my when I first started
school striking the 20th of August it's
on Tuesday I think
yes it's the anniversary of mine when I
suppose that a school striking the 20th
of August
and I will see how I will celebrate the
day and I don't know yet but I think I
will definitely think about it I said I
know it's one year today and I don't
know if
yeah
I mean I don't really care how my name
is pronounced I think it's fun that
everyone pronounces it differently but I
say grandpa to die
and of course I brought many
like not not that much clothes because
I'm going to wear clothes like these and
but like books and like some kind of
board games which doesn't fall around
too much and yeah
yes I have one little rabbit which I
received from someone I know
for this trip
not any any big is this specific plan
as I always say I would just have to
take that promise and work together with
lots of other people and activists and I
mean experts to try together to to make
as much difference in improvement as
possible I start Ben Webster again what
do you say to millions of other European
teenagers who dream of going to America
are they likely to ever
I mean that's not something I can also
do they can go there if they want to so
I I think that is something you have to
steal until someone else
if I were to choose one thing that would
be achieved from this trip or these
summits or then I would say if I want to
choose one thing I would say increased
awareness among people in general and so
that people start realizing that we are
in an emergency and that they know the
background and what is required to
prevent the worst consequences because
if enough people are aware then they
will start to to care about this and
then in turn they will create
international opinion and people can
together put pressure on the people in
power so that they so that they will
have to do something
I don't anything else
for sports sailing
yes definitely that is
since as I said this is such a big
global issue which goes beyond
like areas and then I mean this needs to
be tackled from every possible angle and
sport reaches a lot of people which can
definitely be be useful in spreading
awareness of this
of course
we started many years ago too and we
started many years ago on different
sailing voyages to include school
teachers to help set school classes and
children following the adventures at sea
and then talk about the animals at sea
and and also what's retton's the oceans
and the oceans is pretty much very much
where climate change is happening and
and so we we have a school teacher in
our team to organise fastest retires
from all kinds of countries to follow
one of them
that's really you need you to study
I mean I won't need to do it because I'm
taking a gap year but I will definitely
never stop learning and if I get bored I
will just start to read about something
that I find interesting and yeah if I
can yeah I always find time to to learn
more
[Applause]